[Musique]
nous sommes payés à la tâche
je tends attente au restaurant le temps
qu'on met pour quitter de notre position
au restaurant il n'est pas pris en
compte
en un an j'ai durel et le prix des coups
ç'a été divisé pratiquement par dieu
donné à manger c'était maintenant je
rempile mois dernier ma tante et
resterons ouverts comme par hasard ça
coïncide avec des et des poteaux des
staffs des insultes et des gens sympas
aussi centre éthique on jamais de tenir
compte des esclaves frasques et quand tu
y travailles tu dois te fais quand même
à l'image de ces livreurs à vélo des
millions de travailleurs dans le monde
oeuvre aujourd'hui pour des plateformes
numériques
les start-up devenus des géants comme
hubert ou des livres ou qui ont recours
à des travailleurs indépendants
rémunérés à la tâche sans contrat de
travail est souvent sans protection
sociale une bataille est engagée
des élus des avocats des travailleurs
tentent de s'opposer aux excès de l'ubs
et risation ce modèle social économique
s'extrait de la responsabilité sociale
qu'est celle des commerçants des
artisans des entreprises c'est un modèle
aussi qui comment dire des humanistes
complètement la relation de l'activité
mais leur combat est loin d'être gagné
car l'univers des plateformes numériques
s'étend désormais à toutes sortes de
métiers
[Musique]
je m'appelle shimon nabil j'habite à
lille j'ai de 54 ans je suis chauffeur
de vtc depuis quatre ans je fais ça pour
les clients pour que les clients après
chaque course il note le chauffeur ça va
de une seule étoile à 5 étoiles et comme
je suis un mec soigneux et tout et je
veux que je te le client à la fin de la
course il me met toujours le cinq
étoiles au début une habile il croyait à
fond à fond à fond on voyait les
publicités partout un peu partout
envoyez les belles voitures on
on pensait que c'était la belle vie moi
je pense y travailler places et d'un
autre côté acheté une maison pour mes
enfants ma femme ait quitté le petit
appartement gilles on parlait de 7000
euros par mois et tout ça
j'aime bien rouler marc j ai tout
concorde
allez on va s'installer envolée alors ça
on va aller aux as pauvre déclaré on va
au rif on va prendre un numéro et puis
voilà
jeudi l'un des meilleurs shows faire
avec des appréciations de l'application
viber envoyés chaque semaine qui me
disait vous êtes le driver numéro 1 de
lille
moi j'étais fier d'être l'un des
meilleurs sur ce raid in
nabil travail avec l'application itx
loin de ses rêves de richesse
il gagne tout juste un smic pour nourrir
sa famille les journées sont à rallonge
10 à 12 heures en moyenne c'est le qg
des chauffeurs hubert-delisle ouais on
va essayer au bois noté le patron il
connaît il y a les numéros de toutes les
voitures et deux cars avec des quais
besoins en cours en course privé il peut
nous il peut aussi nous appeler
ça sonne et j'ai une course ce soir les
courses se font rares la veille nabil a
beaucoup travaillé c'était la fête de la
musique
on a fait un petit 200 ans c'est une
très bonne journée le temps j'ai fait
quinze heures de conduite deux sens au
départ à 15 heures j'ai mis mes la
moitié d'un plat naissance qu'il faut
enlever l'usure de la voiture pour
tomber sur nos sommet vraiment travers
de conduite il faut les faire
[Musique]
nabil dépend de l'application pour
travailler mais supportent seuls les
charges liées à son activité
ce modèle pascal savoldelli le dénoncent
depuis longtemps
le sénateur communiste a été l'un des
premiers parlementaires à croiser le fer
avec les plateformes
entre parets à wes ont fait 1
trois ans quand sa raison d'être
en au total assurances la naissance nous
pascal savoldelli a écrit une
proposition de loi pour mieux protéger
ses travailleurs
il ya un an j'ai déposé un projet de loi
aucune possibilité de statut salarial
c'est à dire que vous ayez droit à une
protection sociale des congés chômage
voilà et penser à un truc vous êtes tous
des garçons mais moi je suis beaucoup
plus vieux que vous mais il ya des
femmes qui vont être aussi dans ses
activités dans les plates formes de
travail
israël devrait avoir droit au projet
maternité alors que là c'est une femme
elle travaille dans une plate forme
numérique de travail
elle n'y a pas droit en soi au delà de
la précarité de ces travailleurs
le sénateur alerte sur le rôle des
algorithmes véritable donneur d'ordre
échappant au droit du travail
ces algorithmes personnes en a la
maîtrise et ceux qui déterminent vos
conditions de travail vont re s'ouvre
combien vous êtes rémunéré l'algorithme
ccc c'est ce qui fait la la nature et la
relation de l'activité c'est extrêmement
important donc dans la dans le projet de
loi que nous avions déposé le logo
communistes républicains l'écologiste et
citoyens nous avions mis dans nos toiles
le fait que tous ces travailleurs
puissent avoir un data scientiste un oui
data scientiste 6 à quelqu'un qui est
capable de décortiquer
l'algorithme donc de comprendre comment
s'organise l'activité qui décide comment
ça se décide et à quelles conditions
donc c'est un enjeu extrêmement
important il faut une transparence
la proposition de loi de pascal
savoldelli a été rejetée et l'opacité
demeure nabil en a fait l'expérience à
l'époque où il travaillait exclusivement
avec la plateforme hubert j'ai pris
deux garçons on arrête de la voiture et
puis la course s'est mal passé avec lui
il faisait des trucs que moi je voulais
pas qu'ils fassent dans le véhicule et
en sortant du véhicule eut envoyé
directement
moi j'ai pas pu moi j'avais les courses
qui enchaîné ils m'ont dit vous êtes
déconnecté définitivement je n'ai pas pu
m'exprimer j'ai même pu lire un mot avec
quelqu'un avait quelques adumin qui me
posent des questions que je réponds rien
rien ne s'est fait normalement dans
machine m'a dit au revoir et c'était la
has et un au revoir et à dieu nous ont
même pas cherché à savoir est ce que
c'est vrai ce que c'est fou et monde est
connecté par une machine par
l'algorithme qui m'a répondu
privé de ressources du jour au lendemain
nabil a rejoint la lutte
il s'est tourné vers brahim ben ali ce
lillois a fondé le premier syndicat
indépendant de chauffeur vtc
[Musique]
comment ça on checke on donne le coup de
coude ici c'est le bastion des vtc
si on peut le dire c'est à dire que
c'est là que on se rassemble et de nuit
comme de jour
on apprend petit à petit que nos
collègues sont déconnectés voilà pour
rien en plus avec la baisse tarifaire tu
rappelles quand ils ont commencé à
baisser le prix le tarif
horokilométrique il avait baissé donc la
honda c'est à ce moment là qu'on a
commencé à se parler les uns les autres
et on a eu un petit noyau de 70,5 je
crois c'était ça et c'est de là que tout
a démarré que notre combat il ya cinq
ans maintenant ça y est un stepper ses
c'est lui qui nous emmenait un peu
partout on fait ça on fait telle action
hôtel actions et non suez et nabil c'est
un peu le on va dire le papa un peu de
beaucoup de vtc le papa que respectable
et du coup beaucoup ont mal pris quand
il était déconnecté c'est quand même de
là qu'on a commencé à ajustements sont
révélés
[Musique]
brahim ben ali est devenu
l'interlocuteur des plateformes
il faut que je parle la pénibilité au
travail parce qu'on l'a mais c'est trop
court fait quatre minutes je peux rien
dire que oui bonjour merci de me laisser
pouvoir intervenir pourquoi aujourd'hui
ces chauffeurs là sont déconnectés sans
raison alors que hama théâtre prise
hubert dit voilà ce sont des
indépendants ils exercent sans
contrainte
ils sont libres de pouvoir accepter ou
des courses ou pas et en fait non en
fait c'est une supercherie revoir la
procédure
effectivement il reste aux faussaires et
à s'engager est désormais
systématiquement un outil parfaitement
pour la raison de la suspension ou via
des connections au sein des équipes
huppées effectivement les modifications
le combat que mène brahim ben ali au
niveau syndical
d'autres le porte devant la justice
[Musique]
on va faire on va faire deux tasses et
c'est ce que l'on a sélectionné ce qu'on
a écarté ici vous avez une seule
audience de dossiers des lives et où
donc plusieurs coursier qui nous ont
transmis toutes leurs pièces
l'avocat kevin mention défend près de
500 travailleurs de plateformes
numériques et il a un angle d'attaqué
c'est la plateforme qui définit ses
propres règles et qui les imposent aux
coursiers ou vtc aux travailleurs
prétendument indépendants ils contrôlent
la situation de travail comme un
employeur il donne des ordres des
directives
ils vérifient comment le travail est
fait et ils peuvent aussi vous
sanctionner comme des salariés donc là
on n'est plus dans l'indépendance le
prétendu indépendant de fix rien ni les
prix ni les conditions travail ni les
horaires ni quoi que ce soit donc on est
dans du salariat déguisé faut qu'on
multiplie les preuves c'est pas un
travail simple c'est un travail de
fourmi
il faut comprendre comment la plateforme
marche et obtenir un maximum d'éléments
la difficulté dans ces dossiers c'est
que la loi a mis en place ce que l'on
appelle une présomption de non salariat
donc quand un indépendant attaque la
plateforme en justice c'est à lui de
prouver qu'il n'était pas indépendant et
qu'il était traité comme un salarié et
donc la plateforme se cache derrière ça
en disant nous on est juste une
plateforme de mise en relation comme
leboncoin c'est l'exemple qui cite
souvent on a des annonces qui sont
passés et puis après ils se débrouiller
entre eux donc c'est à dire que le
coursier se débrouille avec le
restaurateur pour faire sa livraison
les plateformes ne ferait que de la mise
en relation un argument répété par
hubert encore récemment devant le sénat
malheureusement il faut souvent continua
à la raclée du beurre avec une
entreprise de technologie et bien
évidemment est une application en
finlande deux applications
d'intermédiation uniquement au départ
über c'était uniquement d'intermédiation
dans le monde des vtc donc la mise en
relation entre des chauffeurs désormais
professionnels et des passagers et
depuis 2007 nous avons également une
activité de livraison à domicile
kevin mention va plaider la cause
d'anciens livreur de la plateforme tekki
tizi qui a depuis fait faillite
aujourd'hui c'est une audience avec 18
coursier qui demandent à être reconnus
comme salarié puisqu'ils ont été virés
du jour au lendemain on revient devant
un juge professionnel aujourd'hui pour
que le dossier soit tranchée pour la
première fois en première instance et il
espère du coup récupérer beaucoup de
salaires impayés de congés payés
d'indemnité de rupture et secteur à
qu'ils n'ont pas pu avoir
du fait de ce faux statut d'indépendant
saleh
- ça c'est en notre faveur on va croiser
les doigts on va déposer les gros
dossiers
on a monté pendant toutes ces années
avec ce que vous nous avez donné au fil
de l'eau et puis ce que vous avez pu
regrouper entre eux ou ce système plus
important aussi pour prouver tout ce qui
s'est passé
et puis on va essayer de vous obtenir
tout ce que vous auriez dû avoir à
l'époque on va rentrer à l'intérieur
l'avocat sait qu'il a un atout dans sa
manche la jurisprudence en mars 2020 la
cour de cassation a tranché du verre une
nouvelle fois épinglé par la justice
la cour de cassation confirme la
requalification comme salarié d'un
chauffeur indépendant qui travaillait
avec cette application
la cour estime que ce chauffeur n'avait
pas de clientèle propre ne fixait pas
ses tarifs n'était pas libre de ses
prestations n'avait pas le choix de ses
courses
bref ils n'étaient pas réellement
indépendant l'audience s'est très bien
passé le conseil connaissait déjà ce
type de dossier donc il avait lui-même
en tête encore nos arguments je pense
qu'on aura gain de cause sur l'existence
d'un contrat de travail
la jurisprudence de la cour de cassation
est très importante dans le dossier je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les juridictions
c'est le cas jusqu'à présent et compris
en première instance ou en appel
vont suivre le mouvement et confirmés
qui a bien du salariat déguisé
[Musique]
des victoires au cas par cas mais
jusqu'à présent les tentatives de
légiférer pour tous les travailleurs
échoue
[Musique]
olivier jacquin et sénateurs de meurthe
et moselle est agriculteur céréalier
avoine un bétail
en tant qu'agriculteur et indépendant
olivier jacquin et sensible au sort des
travailleurs des plateformes pas
forcément des revenus réguliers peut
être sujet à des contraintes de marché
de météo comme moi en agriculture etc et
donc ils capitalisent et il a les moyens
de son indépendance en constituant plus
ou moins patrimoine c'était vrai avec
les artisans taxis qui vendaient leurs
plaques qui leur faisait un complément
de retraite
c'est le cas avec moi agriculteurs 57
ans j'ai plus grandes empreintes de
l'installation
si j'ai un coup dur je peux faire tampon
mais le chauffeur de vtc illac sa
voiture à revendre le livreur à vélo il
a rien impôts vélo qui se fait voler une
fois sur deux
olivier jacquin a écrit une proposition
de loi pour empêcher le dévoiement du
statut d'indépendant c'est l'idée de
présumer salariés les travailleurs de
plateformes sont alors empêché d'être
indépendants s'ils ne sont pas
indépendants fictifs
si ces puissante plate forme est il
estime qu'elle ne subordonnent pas leurs
travailleurs et qu'ils sont
effectivement des indépendants qu'elle
en fasse la démonstration
mais pour les autres ainsi ils auront
une vraie protection et des vraies
conditions de travail normales et s'ils
sont vraiment salariés bien ma foi ils
sont salariés
il ya d'ailleurs des plateformes qui
utilisent des travailleurs à haute
qualification sous la forme du salariat
ça se passe pas toujours mal on n'est
pas contre toutes les plateformes n'est
pas contre l'économie numérique mais pas
ces dévoiements dans la discussion
générale la parole à monsieur olivier
jacquin auteur de la proposition de loi
pour diriger
j'aurais pu imaginer quel retour au
cachot nage dans leurs pires cauchemars
on partage ce constat pour poursuivre on
doit trouver un chemin effectivement
pour permettre le développement de ces
emplois
alors vous voyez monsieur le sénateur
jacques 1 ce n'est pas parce que nous ne
prenons pas le même chemin qu'il faut
caricaturer la position du gouvernement
et vous le savez très bien que je suis
aussi déterminé que vous a donné des
droits à ces travailleurs
le texte d'olivier jacque 1 n'a pas
passer l'étape du sénat où la majorité
de droite partagent l'avis du
gouvernement sur les plates formes sur
le principe le gouvernement est
favorable au développement des
plateformes numériques qui permettent de
développer des nouvelles activités et
donc de créer des nouveaux emplois mais
évidemment il faut s'assurer que ça ne
se fait pas au détriment des
travailleurs qui doivent bénéficier de
droits sociaux comme l'ensemble des
travailleurs en france en avril
on a également pris une ordonnance qui
je pense est une base importante pour
établir ses droits des travailleurs des
plateformes qui va permettre d'organiser
une représentation collective des
travailleurs des plateformes et donc du
coup de les mettre en situation de
négocier avec les plateformes soit au
niveau du secteur soit au sein de
chacune des plateformes négocier des
sujets importants comme la tarification
comme les conditions enfin la
transparence sur les algorithmes et puis
la protection sociale
la ministre du travail mise donc sur le
dialogue entre plateformes et
travailleurs pour améliorer la situation
elle propose que des travailleurs sans
papiers des migrants à dialoguer avec
des plateformes internationales
c'est ça le dialogue social c'est ça la
réalité à dialoguer avec hubert et ses
milliards d'argent de chiffre d'affaires
et son lobbying incroyable et d'arracher
quelques droits on nous parle de quoi
d'avoir une couverture accidents du
travail
olivier jacquin repart au sénat
poursuivre le combat
il rejoint une mission d'information
lancée par son collègue pascal
savoldelli pour enquêter sur l'ubs et
risation et ses conséquences quel impact
ont les plates formes sur les métiers et
l'emploi
la question du management slan de
l'algorithme de son rôle de
subordination
comment se construit la décision et les
conséquences sur les métiers la
formation sur l'emploi l'art est au
coeur du travail de la mission car le
modèle des plateformes pourrait changer
en profondeur le monde du travail
une évolution que l'avocat kevin mention
observe aux premières loges bonjour
madame c'est pour le dépôt d'une requête
alors une saisine directe du bureau de
jugement
[Musique]
parfait à très bientôt très bonne fin de
journée
merci à voir l instant nous venons de
déposer un dossier contre stuart qui est
une filiale de la poste et qui faisait
travailler une personne sans papiers
pour livrer à pied des courses monoprix
sur le modèle de l'ubs et risation comme
les délits verrou hubert etc et qui
propose de livrer beaucoup de choses y
compris des paquets chronopost à la
place de vrais facteurs salariés et vous
pouvez par exemple vous faire livrer vos
courses avec stuart stuart filiale de la
poste a recours à des travailleurs auto
entrepreneurs
signe que le modèle des plateformes
dépasse désormais largement les seuls
secteurs des vtc et de la livraison de
repas
et c'est en petit à petit à tous les
métiers
[Musique]
laver et repasser du linge chez soi pour
des particuliers faire des petits
travaux ou monter un meuble ikea servir
dans un restaurant où faire la plonge en
cuisine exercé en tant que photographe
professionnel et même travaillé comme
aide soignant pour chacun de ces métiers
sont apparus ces dernières années des
plateformes numériques
elle s'appelle staff me brigade koassi
où tu as crabit et propose à des
travailleurs indépendants des missions
ponctuelles
[Musique]
ça va damien geignard vite à nantes
il fait parti des travailleurs rue berri
s'est défendue par l'avocat kevin
mention je suis devenu coursiers à vélo
après une expérience qui s'est mal fini
chez mcdo ou ans patron d'une paye et
pas mes salaires donc il fallait que je
retrouve un autre boulot c'est là que je
me suis dit pour devenir coursiers à
vélo il ya pas besoin d'être salarié et
puis ça laisse ça laisse une certaine
liberté tant que en tant qu'activité
complémentaires en fait du coup j'ai
commencé ça comme ça puis c'est devenu
après rapidement une activité à temps
plein après trois ans de livraison
damien cherche autre chose
un jour il découvre la plateforme staff
me choisit quand tu veux travailler
acceptant les offres sont d'être
pénalisé le même discours que sur toutes
les plateformes a de toute façon de
libéralisation quoi
[Musique]
j'ai eu pas mal de missions différentes
avec sa famille j'ai fait des
inventaires sur la première mission que
j'avais fait alors ça a duré trois
semaines
j'ai fait pas mal de déménagement avec
eux j'ai fait des missions de voiturier
à l'aéroport de chauffeur de navettes la
mission la plus courte que j'ai eu à
effectuer
c'était justement un déménagement ça a
duré une heure et demie donc voilà c'est
ce point des journées où j'avais dû
bloquer ma journée pour cette mission
pour gagner du coup 18 euros bruts de
chiffre d'affaires
sauf me s'occupe des maîtres les
factures en notre nom pour l'entreprise
pour laquelle on travaille on n'a même
pas là la corvée entre guillemets devoir
faire la facture soit même si exactement
comme si on recevait un bulletin de paie
on reçoit la facture qu'on est censé
avoir émis nous mêmes
l'été dernier mon annoncé que j'arrivais
sur mes 31 ans et que donc je serai trop
vieux pour travailler avec eux donc ils
ne me proposerait plus de nouvelles
missions
[Musique]
damien attaque staff ni pour
discrimination sur l'âge
aujourd'hui les chefs cuisiniers il a un
cdi
les plateformes pour lui c'est terminé
mais pour les deux cent mille personnes
en france qui travaille pour une
plateforme numérique
rien n'est encore acquis en 2022 est les
liront des représentants pour négocier
de meilleures conditions de travail
devant le sénat les poids lourds du
secteur vente déjà les mérites de cette
négociation à venir
on constate qu'il ya une appétence pour
ce dialogue social et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous nous réjouissons des
travaux qui ont été je voudrais rappeler
que les bateaux ancrés l'emploi est à la
fois flexible et accessible et ça nous
semble être un poids important
un enjeu qui est très important c'est
que chaque livreurs et son mot à dire et
se sentent libres de créer son
association ou même son syndicat
finalement le seul document qu'on
demande passer le diplôme c'est très
important ça permet l'accès à l'emploi
pour des populations qui sont éloignés
pour différentes raisons et qui met
ainsi un pied sur le marchepied qui
ensuite vont vers d'autres vers notre
occupation
l'enjeu est capital pour nous c'est
vraiment de pouvoir allier sécurité
d'une part et flexibilité d'autre part
[Musique]
malgré ses promesses de dialogue social
les adversaires des plates formes
restent mobilisés
qu'ils redoutent l'apparition d'un
nouveau statut sur le marché de l'emploi
une situation hybride pour ces
travailleurs chaque jour plus nombreux
ni indépendant vraiment libres ni
salarié réellement protégés
coil
chat
[Musique]